magnus doesn't have that luxury okay
meanwhile we do see a trade of a set of
pawns in the center
um both sides just with very solid
positions here i think magnus will be
happy with the outcome of this opening
just because there's not too much action
it's the type of position where you can
just close your eyes for a minute or two
there's no direct attack but it's
magnus's move now and is he aware
this is he knows very strange
is magnus crossing asleep no i i think
he's recording he must be recalling some
variation that he's looked at i say that
and i'm like hang on a minute
i'm not sure you can't you can't have
just fallen asleep at the board i mean
uh
uh been like that for
a few minutes should we give him a shove
look at the breathing his hand okay the
breathing does show sorry his hand is in
the mouth though do you sleep with the
hand rested like that well minus wood
most natural position he couldn't have
just walked in and fallen asleep but if
you're really tired it's actually
awesome
you know when you wake up